un très beau lancer de donetsk je ne
répliquent guillaume genton ensuite nous
avons attention déjà dû aligner pour
rire genton pas mal est bloqué a été
bloqué à son attention attention
allez-y taper si ces mamies réfléchissez
pas trop longtemps plume amis quand même
pour l'instant sur ce il a attend comme
cole côté bien compté c4 c4 pions quatre
pions aligner attention pas mal pas mal
attention attention attention une
réplique pour l'instant le match est
parfaitement équilibré c'est un duel de
titans écrit et d'anti temps il ya team
merci bien évidemment attention
attention attention
mais non quoi mais non il a fait une
grosse erreur magnon pourquoi n'en est
rien je réfléchissais bien guillaume
lapp et si c'est bien vous n'avez pas
regardé le jeu que j'avais vu les
bienvenus
allez-y regardez bien les abeilles
il n'y a rien au jeu mégane et mégane
dont on ne sait pas comment
et non il fallait qu'ils sont prompts à
les y ont été mes proches
mais ce qu'il a fait aulas il a ripé il
arrivé au lycée
voilà voilà attention tu es à côté à
cocody à côté mènera mais là et là oui
mais oui là bravo
non mais vous êtes très amènera t
alors au nom des gens le nicaragua
nicole remontée savourer des mets déjà
essayé hier de six drones arrive pas
enfin celui qui allait tenir au moins 10
secondes remporte le point si c'est pas
possible j'ai alors allez-y gilles bien
c'est mal et l'a compris s'ils cèdent
avec le petit canton du jura l'isi
attention mais nommé alex qui vous est
donnée trois seniors
attention 3
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
alors je vais à métrage à gagny alors
c'est moi a annon cé moi je pense que
non non non attendez je vais demander à
la régie merci à lui a perdu tes voilà
attendez je pense que et non à yepes
baladé contre moi je pense que ce n'est
pas pour des questions de sécurité
il serait préférable nous avons sûrement
la compétition bravo bravo bravo famille
qui signifie pour moi un peu de câbles
3,82 à
bah oui c'est normal
non mais attendez j'ai remonté à
bordeaux un point bas tout ça se joue
maintenant
émettons même jugé normal ce n'est pas
gagné non ah bon vous êtes tombé en même
temps il est resté solide quoique sur
essai c'est ce point
tout se joue sur ça si vous avez joué
gilbert ds ou bernard montiel peut-être
que je parte famille bongo
attention attention 3 2 go
je te vois alors voilà déjà que cheryl
j'avais beaucoup à leurs nombreux
[Rires]
invités qui sait imiter personne voulait
didier deschamps il ya beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui doit il se sont
penchés sur son cas est décédé mail
gmail et autres animateurs qui est en
train sur la scène dans la salle est
bien des dégâts et avait tout est
éphémère
l'espace sont fait la malle ou la
pelouse
ouais je n'ai pas demandé la saisie des
secondes ou pas il est droit là ils ont
dit on arrête quand tu t'arrêtes non
mais j avais culotte comme ça a été tu
commence à nous coûter de merde 1500
balle on arrête tout on recommence
je suis toujours là je voudrais juste
vous remercier et ça me fait très
plaisir de tous voix raymond thierry tu
sais que je t'aime je suis tellement
content de te voir et c'est vraiment ça
me fait très plaisir j'ai envie de
t'embrasser c'était pas comme si c'était
un pli je te jure je te jure c'est non
on aurait fait j'aurais toujours
rétorquer de récup et comment ça va
c'est après vente et acier côté d'eux
mais aussi ben sur un canapé temps